il faudrait que ces drames la illustre
les difficultés de l'accès à l'éducation
pour les autochtones qui résident dans
des réserves qui sont souvent très
éloignés très éloignées l'exemple du
nord évidemment c'est un exemple massi
criant là de vérité pour ce genre de
problème là c'est qu'effectivement quand
vient le temps d'aller dans des
établissements secondaires ou post
secondaires les infrastructures ne sont
pas là alors soit on reste sur la
réserve et là on est on est une faible
scolarisation ou alors on décide de
quitter le nid familial à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de là et on se
retrouve dans une ville parfois on n'a
plus du tout les points de repère et
résultats avaient bien souvent ça crée
un phénomène de décrochage scolaire
majeur chez les autochtones et dans
certaines régions dans certaines
communautés ça peut atteindre jusqu'à 80
% de taux de décrochage scolaire c'est
dans ouais il faut quand même rappeler
que dans les réserves le système
d'éducation est financé par le
gouvernement fédéral
c'est un dock tout s'est vraiment
linverse des non autochtones que nous
sommes c'est à dire que l'en général ce
sont les provinces qui administre cet
argent dans ce cas-ci ce fédérale alors
voici justement quelques chiffres pour
vous donner un petit peu une idée de ce
que représente cet investissement à
fédéral pour les autochtones qui
majoritairement proviennent des réserves
regarder 2005 2006 c'était un milliard
deux cent soixante dix millions et vous
le voyez d'année en année ça grain d'à
peu près une moyenne de 3%
les derniers chiffres donc 2012-2013 là
c'était un milliard 622 1000 est ce
assez pour combien de personnes et bien
en fait ça concerne environ 113 me
autochtones qui majoritairement suivre
leur scolarité sur les réserves d'autres
vont dans certaines écoles fédérales ou
provinciales
ça peut paraître beaucoup d'argent sauf
qu'il faut tenir compte évidemment de
beaucoup d'éléments la wii d'ailleurs le
conseil en éducation des premières
nations dit d'abord ces chiffres en
l'air important mais en fait une
prennent pas en considération de choses
notamment le coût de la vie sur les
réserves et surtout le boom
démographique auquel sont confrontés en
fait les premières nations
il ya un taux de natalité énorme il ya
une croissance démographique beaucoup
plus forte que celle des non autochtones
résultats par exemple quand le fédéral
va débloquer de l'argent pour construire
des infrastructures par exemple les
écoles
ça prend quelques années avant que ce
soit complété une fois que la porte
s'ouvre et bien bien souvent à cause du
boom démographique déjà on a des écoles
qui ne sont plus adaptées et là bas on
revient
problème du début c'est à dire que la
moins d'infrastructures disponibles
adapté vers ce moment là il ya plus de
taux de décrochage scolaire résultat
mais on quitte on va dans les grandes
villes puis là il ya d'autres problèmes
keaven s'appuie donc on le voit c'est un
problème très complexe pour les
autochtones l'éducation les jeunes dont
on parle
c'était la première fois pratiquement
qui sortaient de leur réserve et se
retrouve dans un leu heureusement loin
de leurs parents
merci beaucoup fréquents